Look at a human being and say,
you deserve to be under one roof with the people that you love,
but does that give you a right to break into my house?
[inaudible] house?
Yeah.
Hello,
I'm Adam [inaudible] and I am a proud undocumented storyteller and my name is
Swan Camilo [inaudible] for the green goes C.
I'm a singer,
an actor.
I'm done jelly.
I'm a spoken word artist and a paralegal and I was undocumented for 12 years.
Jonathan Miranda and I'm pro ball.
Hi,
I'm Julie.
I'm,
I'm a Grad student and I'm also undocumented.
Jasmine,
Anna Saavedra.
I'm an immigrant.
I came to this country through the legal process.
The first statement is I feel threatened by the other side.
That's
course.
The day after Trump's inauguration,
I phoned my mother,
Essex am trying to find out how much it would cost to ship our washing machine
to the Dominican Republic.
She said,
I just want you to be ready in case immigration comes.
Ever since it has felt like my family and my community has been taking punches
over and over and over again,
trying to prove our humanity that we deserve.
Basic human rights.
I think it was never about a very specific country and a very specific legal
status.
I think it was a fear of everyone who is different.
He put forth the Muslim ban and through that process a lot of people lost their
green card.
There's their permanent residence status too,
and after that he came after birthright citizenship,
undocumented immigrants and I think Mexican undocumented immigrants in
particular were the first to take the hit.
But that category is going to continue to grow and it's going to consume a lot
of us.
Well,
I feel that tag by the other side Jews because I love this country juice because
I respect the law here.
I feel attack where they cannot feel free to support my precedent because they
profiled me as a bad person just because I want the best for the people in this
country.
We said the t word
as a Latino,
I'm already putting this box that I'm supposed to think this way.
I'm supposed to act this way.
I'm supposed to just assumingly go with my group.
Trump said very specific things and that gets twisted around and presented as
like,
well,
he thinks all people,
all Mexicans are rapists.
I was like,
that's not what he said.
The Muslim ban,
it wasn't a Muslim ban.
They're banning specific countries that were already banned under Obama,
so to call it a Muslim ban is a very wide umbrella of association.
Eileen,
I feel threatened by his,
by media.
It is by identity politics is that you were,
JC was saying like first off,
I don't have a problem with the stories you guys have.
You come to America for betterment,
but sadly you're a minority of another minority of people that do come across
the border for other not good intent purposes.
The reason why I talked mostly about Mexico is because it's right on our
southern border is right there and our border is totally whack.
It's weak.
It's nothing there.
That's why I voted for Trump and a wall is because even though you didn't come
through the legal process,
I still want you to be protected.
But also,
you know,
president Trump hubby saying that he wanted to help the good illegal people,
the people who really love this country.
I mean because you need to Sec.
No,
everyone is good.
I mean you can be here illegally and be respectful to this country.
I love this country.
I think there's a theme here,
this theme of Legality,
the way in which Trump supporters have used this idea of legality has been
completely incorrect and dismissive of this country's history.
If you were to use nothing argument 60 years ago when segregation was legal,
you could have said,
I don't want a black people and this and this restaurant because the law says
that white people and black people shouldn't be in the same spot.
I have the right to impose that law.
Last change laws can be unjust.
I believe in America first.
Awesome.
I actually believe in America first,
but I believe every country should have that.
Anything.
Oh,
do you want America first?
Cause even though these people are not undocumented,
the moment I hope that they gain synergy yet,
but just hopes asap,
then they come to a country that is prepared to give him opportunities in to go
for the goals and dreams that they wished to aspire.
That's like America first.
It's like we start with the individual.
So is your life more important than my life and my world?
My life is more important than your life and I do my best to take care of
myself.
I fill my cup up so that I can fill up your cup.
That was first for me is community.
I don't stand behind any country.
I can't say that.
I think Dominican Republic comes first.
I don't.
I think it's people come first.
America first is such a dangerous concept.
I don't know if you realize,
but that's the reason why we're called the world is constantly at war America
first is about white Americans first.
It's white America first versus the few people from all around different
countries,
different colors who are okay with white America first because they're going to
get the seconds.
And there's always the temptation for me to align myself in that place and say
if I just keep my head down a little bit,
then I will be next in line to cause.
Guess what?
I am more privileged then undocumented immigrants who come from Latin America
who have crossed the border.
And that is shameful to me and I have to every day train myself to put that
thought down because I want to align myself with people.
And I know you said,
how can I think about another family when my own family is hurting?
But why wasn't America thinking about that when it came into the Dominican
Republic when it created an incredibly uneven trading deals with Mexico when it
bombed the hell out of my country,
right.
It wasn't that for America first.
Isn't that why I'm here?
Illegal immigration hurts legal immigration.
Okay.
It's like you're waiting in line to get into this,
this place and for you to,
you know,
go to the back of the line,
stand in line and wait and to watch people cut in line in front of you.
It's a big fuck you to my family.
It's a big fuck you to the whole system.
It's a whole,
it's not a battle wall.
Fuck the wall.
It's about principles that you said.
It's based on principles.
If we waited,
there would be no need for a wall in general.
When you come here illegally and you got cut off,
now you're in a position of being like in the middle class or even in a
worldclass where now you're paying more taxes for someone to not pay taxes and
now you're paying for their education and they was good.
That could go on for your children.
That could have gone for American citizens and now we're giving it to them.
Cause we had a process for a green card in place and guess what?
We waited those two years and what happened was we were denied because they said
your parents aren't making enough money.
That happened two more times.
Every time we were denied,
my parents decided to stay because our entire lives,
we're here,
our entire community,
our church community,
our friends.
When you say there is a right way to immigrate here and there is an illegal way
and you use a big fat label on all of that,
you're really obscuring all these diverse details about people's lives.
It's a,
it's a really dangerous rhetoric when you begin to put good versus bad legal
versus illegal.
Listen,
I crossed into this country.
I migrated,
I walked with my brothers and my mother.
I was a poor kid who had no shoes.
How could I know that there was a legal process and when I came into this
country I absolutely found out what it was to be entering into that legal
process.
I'm in that process,
not 11 years and counting.
So what you're doing is instead of looking up to the systems that are putting
all of this situations and to place,
you are looking down to the people most downtrodden.
We did nothing to deserve this.
It is actually the systems that are at play that you have to look and reflect
and say,
why is this happening to your family?
Why is it that your people about why people those same five two there are
government,
why the one of fly and demand America and that is insulting why that is why you
guys victimize yourself.
There is no victimization.
Mine,
how dare you say that?
There was a victimization between my mother making a very real strategic
decision and logical to say,
I am going to read your night and my kids together to live under one roof.
Everyone have their own story and I'm fine with this but now we're talking about
the thousand of people trying to jump our territory.
Language is important.
How you discuss the people who are,
I mean I'm too tired to feel like,
oh I cannot say this because they're going to get offended.
I'm offended because I'm an American because I'm following the law.
I'm offended because I'm a Christian woman because I'm a woman.
Would principle with model with fate.
Something that's very interesting to me is one religion comes into place,
right and we say,
I am an American,
I am a Christian.
Yet you are unable to put aside the political and look at a human being and say
you deserve to be under one roof with the people that you love regardless of
what the government decides to call you.
But does that give you right to break into my house?
Exactly.
Just break into his house.
Yeah.
Look whose house,
whose house.
The next statement is becoming a legal citizen should be easier.
If you look at the way that the government issues visas,
it's an a completely political system.
Who gets it?
What time,
how many years?
And so when you think about citizenship,
it absolutely should be easier in the legal process,
but let's not lose sight.
The citizenship also means the way that you move about in your values and say,
I can be a citizen of this country because I am a human being
and I think we have to recognize that undocumented immigrants don't want to be
undocumented.
If we were up to undocumented immigrant,
they will go show up,
apply for a green card and then apply for citizenship and that's it.
The system is currently failing because we are not appointing people who are
able to understand why people are coming,
people who are able to connect with the different stories that people are
bringing forth,
but the problem is we need all to agree,
but Ebay legal or illegal
emigration me to be control because you can see what is happening here in
California we see our street looking like a third one.
W I w I would respect that.
I would respect that opinion if I didn't know that more people were leaving the
u s then coming in that undocumented immigrants are not the one predominantly
committing crimes in this country.
You see that people are more likely to leave now then come in here.
Let me tell you this.
I'm sorry to disagree.
When people are complaining about gun,
they say,
oh,
we need gun control because even one life matter,
well the same thing.
Even if they do commend people having committed a crime,
even one life matters.
Let me tell you this.
I have a sister who become a widow at the age of 34 with two little boy because
her husband got killed for that illegal alien.
Um,
my brother in law lives matter.
The Wall for me is a message of low from our precedent to his people because he
went to protect the people from this side of the wall.
Even you guys,
you want to protect everyone from this day,
so the wall,
but we need to understand Hamas first.
How can I help someone far away if I know able to help the people who is close
to me?
The reason why I am so against the wall,
number one,
economically very infeasible.
And number two,
I don't see the wall as being a physical barrier between two countries.
I see it as a very symbolic barrier between people.
People who are running for their lives are still going to come cause trust me,
your desire to live is going to help you find a way to get over some wall.
You know,
that's,
that's not the problem.
Walls,
barricades,
barriers are not the economic moral answer.
Everyone in this room can make America great by finding solutions rather than
finding problems.
That's a lot of people like to do.
We'd like to point out what's wrong and not trying to figure out what we can do
to make it better.
Or we all agree that the immigration system sucks.
Like you do what again,
like you were into the field of,
I'm a Paralegal,
but I've been in Libra representative.
Okay.
And so you know more about an idea,
I don't know,
compared to you.
So I want to hear you more your perspective,
and I'm open to that.
That's what American needs more of.
You have something,
I don't,
your superior in that field.
And if we look at intellect before skin tone or before politics,
that would open up more doors to make America great or make America even better.
It's people who are in this country who want to fight for the betterment of it
is what's making this country great.
I'm kidding.
I appreciate it.
I have so many firsts that I really appreciate it.
Yeah.
Okay.